bonjour Olivier Faure
d'être avec nous député de cette année
20 premiers secrétaire du Parti
socialiste on est ensemble pendant 20
minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse régionale
représentée par Stéphane Vernet de
westfrance bonjour Stéphane bonjour
bonjour
Est-ce que vous saluez la manière dont
le gouvernement Emmanuel Macron géré les
migrants de l'Océane Viking je salue
l'accueil parce qu'il était
indispensable il y avait des femmes des
hommes des enfants qui étaient en danger
maintenant saluer la façon dont ça s'est
passé ce serait beaucoup dire parce que
la réalité c'est qu'on a beaucoup de
tergiverser et que j'ai le sentiment
quand même que
cette question là n'est toujours pas
réglée du président de la République or
si on veut se replacer sur un terrain
plus général on a 234 migrants dans un
bateau qui cherche à accoster c'est
effectivement un sujet de média mais la
réalité c'est que ce sont des dizaines
de millions de femmes qui chercheront à
cacher sur nos côtes dans les prochaines
années si nous ne faisons rien sur le
réchauffement climatique et donc plutôt
que de regarder les choses par le tout
petit bout de la lorragnette il faudrait
les regarder grand angle et se poser la
question de savoir comment est-ce que
nous allons faire pour aider des femmes
des hommes des enfants qui veulent
quitter leur village on parle parce
qu'ils chercherait ici l'Eldorado mais
parce que tout simplement ils ne peuvent
plus vivre chez eux et donc comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour que dans les
prochaines années notamment la question
du réchauffement climatique ne devienne
pas en fait un puissant moteur pour les
mouvements migratoires depuis que le
monde parce qu'elle attribue de l'ONU il
y a quelques semaines il a dit c'est les
pays du Nord à aider les pays du Sud de
l'ONU j'entends que effectivement il y a
toujours des gens pour dire que la
maison brûle et qu'on vient d'ailleurs
mais simplement quand on revient à la
réalité malheureusement rien n'est fait
de manière suffisante je prends un
exemple concret en pleine cop27 il y a
un projet qui est en train de démarrer
en Afrique de l'Est avec total avec le
soutien du président de la République et
ce projet qui s'appelle donc
lycope et bien est un projet qui va
produire 24 millions de tonnes pendant
25 à 30 ans le CO2 qui va être projeté
en atmosphère c'est un projet qui
détruit aujourd'hui toutes l'économie
vivrière sur le long du parcours entre
l'Ouganda et la Tanzanie c'est un projet
qui détruit les écosystèmes locaux avec
une indemnisation qui est très faible
quand elle est versée et donc vous allez
maintenant nous expliquer que ces
gens-là ne peuvent pas venir dans le
continent européen mais la réalité c'est
que depuis que le monde est monde quand
il fait trop froid quand il fait trop
chaud les gens bougent quand ils bougent
ils provoque des conflits ces conflits
transformant en guerre et les gens
fuient aussi la guerre et donc vous
aurez de toute façon cette question à
devant vous si nous nous traitons pas en
profondeur ce sujet et donc 234 migrants
ça n'est pas grand chose par rapport à
ce qui nous attend si nous ne faisons
rien alors ce n'est pas grand chose mais
beaucoup en font une question de
principe elle ce principe c'est le droit
maritime le droit international
normalement ce bateau aurait dû être
pris en charge par l'Italie pas par la
France il y a quelques années il était
pas question pour la France de déroger à
ce type de principe pourquoi est-ce que
le président est le gouvernement
français change le pied pour vous mais
parce qu'il y a un principe qui devrait
nous guider tous c'est le principe
humanitaire et vous ne pouvez pas
laisser des gens qui sont en danger de
mort parce qu'il y a des maladies parce
que il y a de la parce que il y a des
hydratation parce que vous avez des
enfants qui sont à bord et bien vous ne
pouvez pas laisser ce bateau de tournée
et surtout le discours qui consiste à
dire oui mais ça pourrait créer un
précédent on ouvre une brèche ça c'est
repris par plein de gens sur la scène
politique aujourd'hui qui s'inquiète en
disant mais finalement la France va
devenir des destinations privilégiées de
de ce type de bateau et de ce type de
flux migratoire j'entends ce qui est dit
mais j'entends on a tort de dire ça ou
pas mais
vous connaissez cette phrase peut-être
de grave urine qui dit les principes
sont faits pour être abolies être humain
est aussi un devoir et bien écoutez je
pense que cette phrase là devrait nous
faire tous méditer être humain c'est
aussi de voir et donc quand vous avez
des gens qui sont en danger de mort
quand vous avez des gens qui finalement
enfin vous savez que la Méditerranée est
devenue le plus grand cimetière européen
ce sont quasiment 2000 personnes qui
sont mortes depuis le mois de janvier
dans cette mer Méditerranée qui est
notre bien commun avec le sud du monde
et donc il faut un certain moment réagir
aussi et nous sommes enfin qui peut
croire que sur 65 millions d'habitants
on ne peut pas accueillir 234 personnes
c'est qu'ensuite la distribution et vous
avez vu que les pays européens donnaient
à très solidaire ont accepté de prendre
aussi une part de ses migrants donc ne
laissons pas penser non plus que le fait
d'accueillir un bateau en France conduit
à ce que tout serait en France ils vont
pour une la plupart repartir il y a eu
il y a eu un changement de la politique
migratoire l'Union européenne au mois de
juin il était question que les 13 pays
au sein de l'Union soit solidaire avec
les pays premier entrants on parle de
8000 émigrants qui doivent être répartis
la France s'est engagée en 3000
l'Allemagne 3000 mais à ce jour
74 migrants ont été pris par l'Allemagne
sur 3000 58 par la France sur 3000 parce
que ça ça veut pas dire aussi que cette
on est au stade des belles paroles et
que cette solidarité européenne sur la
répartition du migrants elle marche pas
elle fonctionne pas mais je peux pas
dire que ce que vous dites la réalité
c'est que effectivement on est en train
de se plaindre de 134 personnes qui
auraient dû à costernitalie qui a cause
finalement en France
une immense hypocrisie bien sûr et que
la question Olivier fort en lisant
Gérard Collomb parce que Gérard Collomb
qui est une ancienne figure du Parti
socialiste
qu'à s'en tenir je le cite qu'à s'en
tenir à une réaction de sensibilité on
renforce plus le problème qu'on ne le
résout en créant un appel d'air comment
vous avez réagi à ça
je ne peux plus cette expression sur
l'appel d'air vous pensez vraiment que
c'est un appel d'air Collomb mais venant
de n'importe qui enfin cette histoire de
l'appel d'air c'est comme cette histoire
qu'on nous raconte en permanence que les
gens enfin vous imaginer des gens qui
sont dans un village ou au fin fond de
l'Afrique et qui sont là et qui se
disent ah ouais peut-être je vais
toucher les allocations non ce qui se
disent ces gens c'est il y a un avenir
parce que ce qu'il voit sur leur
téléphone sur la télévision etc c'est
qu'il voit que nous sommes des régions
prospères par rapport à des régions qui
sont en fait des régions en détresse et
c'est la raison qu'il est pousse à être
tenter leur chance et à venir sur le
continent européen mais je le répète la
question là qui est devant nous est une
question qui va aller s'accélérant parce
que si vous avez la sécheresse si vous
avez les intempéries si vous avez
l'impossibilité de nourrir votre bétail
de nourrir vos enfants de faire en sorte
que vous puissiez avoir trouvé de l'eau
etc mais que feront ces gens si nous
avons comme c'est actuellement prévu
près de 4 degrés de plus en France à la
fin de ce siècle 4 degrés à Paris ce
sera quand même Barcelone donc là tout
le monde sera content mais imaginez ce
qui se passera dans le sud de l'Europe
et imaginez ce qui se passera dans
l'Afrique subsaharienne mais vous avez
la réponse à la question c'est que il y
a des tas d'endroit où les air avancé et
vous n'aurez pas d'autre choix que de
bouger en qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour ça
c'est ça la question centrale des
prochaines années on va parler d'un
outil on va parler du pouvoir d'achat
puisque demain prend fin la ristourne du
gouvernement sur les carburants sur les
prix à la pompe ça passera de 30 cm à 10
centimes cette histoire n'apprend pas
femme elle est réduite est-ce que le
gouvernement a raison de cibler les
aides pour les plus modestes désormais
oui moi je sais j'avais appelé le fait
que on puisse cibler davantage les aides
et que ce soit pas indifférencier parce
qu'il y a des gens qui évidemment
peuvent payer d'autres qui ne le peuvent
pas bon donc là c'est la bonne méthode
je pense que en tout cas c'est une façon
de régler la question qui ne met pas
étrangère maintenant je savais c'est
toujours la même question c'est sur les
effets de seuil et quels sont les gens
qui vont en bénéficier ceux qui vont
bénéficier en bas il faut dire les
choses telles qu'elles sont aujourd'hui
vous avez beaucoup de Françaises et de
français pour qui la facture énergétique
est devenue un véritable sujet et je
parle des gens je parle aussi des
collectivités locales parce que il ne
faudrait pas oublier le fait que nous
avons je prends les exemples dans ma
propre circonscription la facture
énergétique pour les communes en matière
d'inscription elle est multipliée par
trois ou par 4 personne n'est en dessous
de X3 et donc comment voulez-vous que
les collectivités locales à ciel n'ont
pas de bouclier tarifaire puissent
maintenir les services qu'elles offrent
traditionnellement pensent au gymnase
aux écoles je pense à tout ce qui permet
la vie en collectivité on a vécu des
années terribles avec le confinement la
crise sanitaire où on a perdu un certain
nombre de façons de vivre ensemble il
serait tragique d'avoir demain en plus
à nouveau le repli sur la sphère privée
parce que les lieux collectifs ne sont
plus assurables sur le plan énergétique
et donc il faut un bouclier de tarifaire
pour les collectivités locales comment à
ce bouclier tarifaire ce qu'on en parle
beaucoup on va pour les collectivités
locales on va y arriver vous pensez donc
je ne sais pas si on va si le
gouvernement est prêt à y accéder mais
moi je suis prêt à me battre pour cela
parce que je vois en fait les
collectivités qui sont en fait avec vous
avez des maires dans toute la France les
villes moyennes en fait qui sont occupés
pour les 30 000 communes les plus
petites oui mais en fait les plus
petites il y a 36000 communes en France
donc ça fait 34000 en gros bon ben vous
avez en fait les toutes petites communes
qui vont être accompagnées mais moi je
suis dans des communes qui ont entre
8000 et 30000 habitants et bien en fait
ces communes ne sont pas accompagnées et
c'est tragique parce que ça veut dire
des services en moins et ça veut dire
aussi un mode de vie qui va être très
impacté et des collectivités qui sont
aujourd'hui
attirer la langue alors que ce sont des
communes qui ne sont pas des communes
riches ce qui n'ont aucune capacité à
trouver de l'argent et par le même
moment le gouvernement supprime la CVAE
ce qui va avoir des effets aussi
délétères pour les collectivités locales
et c'est qui veut aussi contrôler mieux
encadré en tout cas les dépenses des
collectivités alors ça avait été
supprimé à l'Assemblée nationale remis
par 49-3 le Sénat va vraisemblablement
un nouveau s'y opposé vous êtes vous
dénoncez cette décision du gouvernement
de vouloir encadrer les dépenses des
collectivités
et qui avait déjà été contesté à
l'époque qui le sont à nouveau
aujourd'hui dans une situation où vous
avez des collectivités qui sont
étranglées et donc c'est toujours la
même chose avec ce gouvernement qui n'a
jamais compris ce qui était les
territoires et ce qui était les
collectivités locales toujours pas la
preuve en est ce que vous annoncez vous
même mais je vous le dis en fait oui ce
gouvernement a un mépris profond pour
les territoires pour les collectivités
locales pour les élus locaux et à chaque
fois c'est toujours à eux que l'on
envoie la patate chaude c'est toujours à
eux qu'on demande de produire des
efforts quand pendant ce temps-là le
gouvernement ne cherche absolument
aucune nouvelle recette il aurait pu
trouver des nouvelles recettes pour
accompagner cette crise énergétique la
solution que j'ai proposée à de très
nombreuses reprises c'est de taxer
notamment les super profits de faire en
sorte que ceux qui aujourd'hui se sont
objectivement gavés sans raison pendant
la crise sanitaire pendant la crise
géopolitique on a crise énergétique qui
ne pour qui leur nouvelle fortune n'est
absolument pas liée à un génie
quelconque qui est simplement lié à des
conditions qui leur sont extérieures et
qui font qu'ils profitent de crises et
qui voilà et donc et là qu'est-ce qu'on
peut demander selon le gouvernement rien
même Bruno Le Maire nous dit ce serait
tellement injuste le Calimero du CAC 40
vous aviez pris initiative vous vouliez
créer un référendum sur cette question
des super profils a été sont toqués par
le Conseil constitutionnel est-ce que
vous allez renouveler cette démarche là
la relancer oui sous quelle forme et
quand nous allons dans la
parlementaire qui viendra en janvier
pour les socialistes et bien nous
remettrons en discussion ce texte parce
que le débat doit avoir lieu et là où le
gouvernement cherche à chaque fois à
l'éviter pendant le débat budgétaire
nous avions déjà remis par voie
d'amendement cette question et à chaque
fois ça nous a été
empêché par le 49 c'est pour reproposer
à nouveau un référendum non c'est pour
proposer directement la mesure et le
référendum c'était une des façons
possibles pour repasser par la fenêtre
là on était bloqué par le 49-3 et comme
le Conseil constitutionnel considère que
l'article 11 va Constitution ne permet
pas de poser la question fiscale et bien
nous nous allons repasser par la voie
parlementaire classique c'est-à-dire par
une proposition de loi et nous verrons à
ce moment-là ce que répondre ça n'a pas
marché là on va voir ce que parce que
pour l'instant c'est le 49-3 qui bloque
à chaque fois moi ce que je veux ce
serait que tous les députés de la
majorité soit conduits à se prononcer et
à dire ce qu'ils sont prêts à faire ou
pas et qu'ensuite mais ce que j'espère
c'est que effectivement ils finiront par
entendre raison parce que si on tente
pas raison nous irons aussi voir leur
propre électeurs en leur disant voilà ce
que votre député a voté il a refusé en
fait de récupérer 20 milliards sur les
supers profits qu'en pendant ce temps-là
on prélève 8 milliards sur l'assurance
chômage le 9 milliards sur les retraites
et on considère que c'est normal mais
écoutez il y a un moment où il faut
effectivement poser les Français devant
les choix qui sont réalisés parce que
cette politique et cette pénurie
organisée elle est pas forcément
simplement le fait du hasard ou le fait
des méchants qui seraient situés à l'Est
de l'Europe elle est aussi le fait de
choix politique qui sont réalisés par ce
gouvernement et il est temps que chacun
en prenne conscience justement un mot
sur l'air traite puisque ce matin dans
une intervieuse écolier du socle des
voiles c'est les premières pistes sur la
pénibilité sur l'emploi des seniors et
il dit vouloir aller au-delà de la
promesse d'Emmanuel Macron qui était de
1100 euros de retraite comme lui il veut
la porter autour de 85% du SMIC vous
êtes satisfait ça fait 30 euros de plus
bah écoutez d'abord c'est comme on est
contrats d'assurance regardez bien en
fait les petites lignes en bas qu'il
faut regarder avec la loupe pardon pour
les assureurs mais enfin c'est quand
même ce que fait le gouvernement vous
n'aurez cette pension minimale qui a une
seule condition c'est d'avoir une
retraite complète c'est-à-dire toutes
vos années de cotisation or qui sont les
gens qui aujourd'hui majoritairement
sont ceux qui ont des retraites
inférieures à ce niveau ce sont les gens
qui n'ont pas pu avoir toutes leurs
années de cotisations et qui doivent
attendre non pas simplement l'âge légal
mais en fait l'âge du taux automatique
et qui est 5 ans après l'âge légal c'est
à dire que en fait si rien ne changeait
il faut attendre 70 ans pour pouvoir
obtenir cette retraite minimale mais qui
sont les gens qui touchera pas à l'âge
de la décote et qui restera à 67 ans
qui sont les gens qui déjà au chômage à
partir de 50 ans vous savez que les
cheveux c'est très compliqué de
retrouver un emploi et de ça qui sont
les gens qui accepteront d'attendre en
fait 15 ans 17 ans pour pouvoir enfin
atteindre cette pension minimale et
comment justifierez-vous le fait que
vous ayez en fait un âge légal et un âge
du taux mécanique automatiques qui soit
aussi proche dans ces cas là en fait il
y a beaucoup de gens qui vont aller
possible pour vous même sur ces
questions
non mais pourquoi parce que c'est pas
simplement une question théorique c'est
parce que qu'est-ce qu'on est en train
de faire qu'est-ce qu'on est en train de
faire le gouvernement il est en train de
dire je veux faire 9 milliards
d'économies sur le dos de ceux qui ont
commencé à travailler plutôt parce que
c'est comme ça que ça ça se passait pour
vous et moi qui ont fait des études
longues la réalité c'est que moi si je
regarde bien si je Vatan dans mes
caranozanés de cotisation il faudra que
j'aille jusqu'à 65 ans à minima mais là
mais pour donc moi je ne suis pas touché
par cette réforme mais celui qui a
commencé à travailler à 16 ans 17 ans 18
ans 19 ans 20 ans celui-là forcément il
va devoiriser plus longtemps pour une
pour une retraite qui sera
identique parce que tout simplement
c'est lui qui va payer ma retraite
est-ce que c'est juste non pourquoi
parce que en plus l'espérance de vie
vous savez très bien entre les cadres et
les ouvriers elle est de 8 ans de
décalage et je parle de la moyenne il y
a bien sûr bien des cas qui sont bien
plus importants dans certaines métiers
dans certaines branches professionnelles
et concernant les autres textes
d'actualité à l'Assemblée en ce moment
quel sera la position des socialistes je
pense par exemple à à la loi
d'orientation de programmation du
ministère de l'Intérieur la loi loopnie
qui est dans l'examen a débuté hier que
qui prévoit 15 milliards de plus sur 5
ans pour les forces de l'ordre du 1500
policiers gendarmes supplémentaires et
comment vont se positionner les
socialistes
comme à chaque fois à chaque fois que ça
ira dans le bon sens
bien au voterons pour quand il y a rien
à redire quand ça va dans le bon sens
mais ça ne va pas assez loin on
s'abstient et quand on est contre on est
contre donc là en l'occurrence sur la
loop mini nous allons voir quel comment
se déroule le débat notamment sur les
questions qui sont liées donc à la
garantie sur la police judiciaire
qu'elle soit pas mise sous l'autorité du
préfet et qu'on n'est pas ça ça va pas
dans le bon sens pour vous ça ça va pas
dans le bon sens et donc on veut des
garanties sur le fait que la police
judiciaire restera maître de ses propres
voilà qu'elle va mettre d'elle-même et
en revanche sur le reste ça va dans le
bon sens
bref effectivement toujours dire que si
on pourrait aller plus loin encore et de
ça mais enfin ça va dans le bon sens
donc
ce sera ou le pour l'abstention ça n'est
pas décidé ça dépend du débat lui-même
parce que dans toute s'il y a pas de
régression c'est des régressions ce sera
contre mais effectivement ce sera on
jugera sur pièce en fonction du débat
d'autres textes qui risque de réaliser
c'est le texte sur la corrida qui sera
examiné la semaine prochaine alors c'est
une proposition de loi d'aymericaro en
député de la France insoumise est-ce que
vous le voterez
il y a pas de là on doit se réunir
aujourd'hui en fait donc dans quelques
heures et on prend une décision je ne
peux pas vous la donner à ce stade il y
aura une décision de groupe pour une
liberté
de vote c'est le débat n'a pas eu lieu
donc je peux pas vous répondre
difficile parce que elle touche aussi à
des traditions qui sont très ancrées et
donc il faut faire attention
peut-être imaginer des solutions
transitoires il faut regarder les choses
avec beaucoup de circonscription plutôt
immédiate
c'est compliqué d'avoir un groupe qui
qui va tout texte du coup j'imagine en
Seine-et-Marne il y a peu de corridas
je sais je sais que les ferias ce sont
des événements qui sont très populaires
ce sont des événements qui mobilisent
des dizaines de milliers de personnes
chaque année et que il faut aussi
laisser vivre
les traditions simplement quand elles
sont cruelles il y a aussi des choses à
inventer et à les inventer avec les
affichesados avec le monde de la corrida
aussi et faire aller vers une évolution
qui permet d'éviter la souffrance
animale on va parler du PS le Parti
socialiste donc vous avez votre congrès
en le fin fin janvier de l'année
prochaine ça va ça va arriver vite il y
a la semaine dernière il y a sept textes
qui ont été
d'orientation générale qui ont été
déposées on pense on dit qu'il y aura a
priori trois notions
à l'arrivée est-ce que vous êtes comment
est-ce que vous appréhendez les choses
notamment par rapport à ces concurrents
vous êtes serein ou vous avez des doutes
on entend beaucoup que vous seriez sur
la sellette en difficulté au sein du
parti ça vous fait sourire
je sais pas s'il faut sourire ou pleurer
ou je ne sais pas enfin la réalité c'est
qu'à chaque fois c'est le même cinéma et
que chacun cherche à montrer les muscles
à expliquer que en danger ou moi je vais
pas vous dire que
du cinéma il y a un vote qui aura lieu
en janvier donc attendez le mois de
janvier c'est un vrai démocratique avec
des militants et des militants qui sont
amenés à trancher est-ce que vous voulez
revenir en arrière ou est-ce que vous
voulez continuer avec cette direction
qui a permis notamment de rassembler
l'ensemble de la gauche et des
écologistes et cette question là et bien
elle sera tranchée par les militants
eux-mêmes et donc tous ceux qui se
spéculent le font toujours PRODOMO et le
fond pour en général parce que ils
aimeraient bien qu'on puisse dire que je
suis menacé et moi je pourrais vous dire
que je ne suis pas je vous dirais pas
non plus parce que je trouve ça ridicule
il y a la démocratie ça se respecte et
quand on attend enfin un résultat on
attend un résultat et le débat vient de
commencer nous allons discuter dans les
fédérations c'est un parti démocratique
secrétaires de fédé départemental sur
100 qui sont favorables donc il y a pas
il y a pas trop il y a pas trop tu as
pas trop d'inquiétude
mais je veux pas rentrer dans la dont je
veux pas commencer à dire combien est-ce
que combien est-ce qu'il y a de
militants qui qui vautront pour les
entre 20 et 25000 pour le vote mais
cette troisième voie puisque c'est ça la
question l'âge que maintenant il y avait
vous qui est trop nul qui avait Hélène
Geoffroy qui est clairement continue et
puis là il y a une troisième voie avec
Nicolas Mayer Rossignol le maire de
France le Nini voilà Patrick a c'est fou
qui le dites Patrick
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette ligne
est-ce que vous pouvez m'expliquer ce
que c'est que cette troisième voie vous
êtes pour ou contre ça je comprends bien
je suis pour le rassemblement de la
gauche et des écologistes je pense que
s'il n'y avait pas eu l'assemblée
écologistes il n'y aurait plus
authentiste à l'Assemblée je pense que
nous n'aurions plus de droit
l'expression que personne aucun
socialiste n'aurait plus sur votre
plateau et donc oui je pense que cette
rassemblement ça aurait été la fin du PS
pour vous mais ça veut dire que on
aurait pas eu de groupe parlementaire ce
que vous auriez vous-même continuer à
accueillir à héberger sur votre plateau
des socialistes qui seraient trois ou
quatre à l'Assemblée non vous auriez
considéré à juste raison que nous
n'étions plus dans le game donc il y a
évidemment une évidence au fait que cet
accord a permis de maintenir une
expression et de permettre de relancer
aussi un parti qui n'était plus
forcément totalement compris et
identifiés là il y avait un choix clair
à faire avec qui on part avec Emmanuel
Macron ou avec le reste de la gauche
nous avons fait un choix qui est simple
mais un choix qui dit ce que nous sommes
dans notre tradition dans notre histoire
dans notre avenir nous sommes de gauche
et nous allons le rester voilà l'ancrage
que moi je souhaite et toutes celles et
ceux qui cherchent à dire on est contre
le rassemblement avec les uns ou avec
les autres qu'est-ce qu'ils veulent
alors où veulent-ils aller quel est en
fait leur centre de gravité vers qui
veulent-ils se diriger qui pense
aujourd'hui
après en 20 ans trois élections
présidentielles ou la gauche c'était ma
présence au second tour parce que
diviser qui pense sérieusement que un
parti n'importe lequel à gauche peut
s'imposer à lui seul même Jean-Luc
Mélenchon qui a fait
19,5 % puis 22% à l'élection
présidentielle au cours des deux
dernières exercices n'a même pas réussi
à être au second tour c'est donc dire
que nous avec nos 6% ou nos 1,7%, nous
aurions embêté bien en peine d'être
second tour aussi donc il faut retrouver
un peu de raison et faire en sorte non
pas de se regarder le nombril de se dire
tiens j'aimerais bien être dirigeant de
tel ou telle partie ne se dire comment
est-ce que je peux faire pour que les
idées auxquelles je crois et les gens
que je défends puissent enfin obtenir la
victoire ça n'a pas permis la victoire à
lupus mais ça a permis de réveiller
l'espoir et de construire un chemin il
n'est pas achevé enfin s'élargir encore
continuer à travailler faire en sorte
que ce projet partagé s'enrichisse pour
pouvoir trouver des électeurs et des
électrices nouveaux mais ça ne veut pas
dire revenir en arrière est considéré
que désormais c'est le chacun pour soi
qui doit l'emporter cette thèse là elle
a déjà été utilisée à le trop nombreuses
reprises et elle a toujours conduit à la
même chose à l'échec à la défaite
trouver un chemin c'est l'argile encore
est-ce que ça veut dire que les
prochaines élections je pense au
sénatorial de 2023 c'est des élections
ou les socialistes se présenteront avec
les la France insoumise les vers les
communistes ou des étiquettes nues et
comment ça va se passer pour les
européennes en 2024 mais à chaque jour
suffit sa peine dans un même façon
je vais vous répondre tout de suite je
vais vous dire exactement comme pour les
législatives en fonction d'un rapport de
force département par département il y
aura des listes qui se feront avec les
forces en présence je peux pas vous dire
mieux c'est exactement ce qui s'est
passé au moment de l'initiative on n'est
pas dans le même rapport de force le
sénatorielle vous avez 80 sénateurs et
la France insoumise n'en a pas un ça
veut dire que le Parti socialiste doit
être moteur pour vous ça me paraît juste
une évidence en fait c'est une évidence
partagée par la France insoumise oui
bien sûr
bien sûr ils sont conscients du fait que
ils ont très peu de des lieux locaux et
donc très peu de grands électeurs donc
bien sûr ils n'ont à présent j'ai
entendu de la part de Manuel Bompard une
revendication extraordinaire qui est
demandé un sénateur bon je crois que on
ne peut pas je crois avoir compris ça la
discussion n'a pas commencé mais ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que bien sûr
qu'ils sont conscients que à chaque fois
que les accords se font sur des bases
qui sont des bases communes appréciables
qui sont à la base de ce que du rapport
de force
il est pas connu le président
bien avant les vacances sur cette
question qui est taraudait et je leur ai
expliqué très clairement ce que je vous
dis là évidemment ça se base sur la
c'est ça sera sur la base un rapport de
force voilà un dernier mot que vous
pensez
ce que vous pensez des déclarations des
Hollandais en avait Stéphane Le Foll sur
notre plateau la semaine dernière qui
disait qu'il fallait ouvrir un débat à
l'extérieur du Parti socialiste et créer
un nouveau mouvement François Hollande
qui dit que le Parti Socialiste n'a plus
d'identité qu'est-ce que vous leur dites
c'est pas parce que ce n'est pas l'heure
identité que ce n'est plus une identité
et il ne faudrait pas que chacun finisse
par considérer que le Parti socialiste
et son propre patrimoine le patrimoine
le socialiste c'est le patrimoine de
tous les Français qui veulent que ça
change et que ça bouge et donc il y a
aujourd'hui une majorité et il y a des
frondeurs des gens qui considèrent que
quand ils ne sont pas servis par
la majorité et bien ils peuvent fonder
expliquer que ce n'est pas la bonne
version des choses pour vous François
Hollande
bien sûr ben écoutez je ne sais pas
comment enfin c'est ce qu'il aurait dit
de n'importe lequel d'entre nous si nous
avions dans son quinquennat était défié
la règle majoritaire il y a une règle
qui est à règle majoritaire je vois que
depuis des mois voire des années il est
ses vertus à fonder à l'extérieur mais
écoutez c'est dommage parce que un
président de la République
un ancien président de la République ne
devrait pas s'abaisser à ça mais écoutez
je veux pas polémiquer non plus avec lui
je respecte à la fois ce qu'il a été ce
qu'il a fait mais je lui dis aussi que
le devoir que nous avons toutes et tous
un moment c'est d'assurer la transition
le passage aux générations qui nous
suivent parce que socialisme c'est aussi
ça c'est un passage de témoin et la
possibilité de cette longue chaîne qui
va de Jean Jaurès jusqu'à nous
aujourd'hui et bien de faire vivre une
flamme et cette flamme elle ne peut
vivre qu'à une seule condition c'est
d'être à la fois unitaire pour ce qui
est de nous concerne mais aussi un avec
le reste de la gauche pour permettre à
la gauche la victoire et avancer une
permanence dans l'histoire c'est que le
Parti socialiste reste le parti des
frondeurs donc
j'aimerais bien que ce soit pas la seule
permanence c'est surtout le Parti du
progrès social le parti de la
transformation est pas simplement le
parti de l'accompagnement d'une logique
libérale qui depuis longtemps a montré
non seulement ses faiblesses mais aussi
ce qu'elle cause sur le plan social sur
le plan climatique et donc il nous
revient dans cette génération de relever
ces défis merci beaucoup Olivier Ford
ïne
c'est un merci beaucoup d'avoir été avec
nous on passe au club de toi